someone showed me this picture of you as
a even younger kid a few years before I
met you when you were modeling and you
can see it when you're a young kid look
at that face
yeah I had a mysterious modeling looks
yeah I think that was the 1991
acid-washed campaign but I also it looks
like you were you can see through
luggage at the airport that's that's the
intensity of your stare yeah I remember
so I was like doing like catalog
modeling or stuff like that like for the
department stores like the newspaper and
apartments like and I'd make $75 a day
mm-hmm and I did two shoots a year and I
made a hundred and fifty dollars a year
and I was rich
when you're a kid that is an incredible
amount of money I could go down to UM
like the kwik-e-mart and buy as many
Slurpees as I wanted to and treat my
friends yeah I would just make it rain
Slurpees that's right and I knew I had
arrived yeah I knew big things we're
gonna happen big things are gonna happen
I knew it then you are a I bet you have
a Slurpee machine in your mansion don't
you yeah today I bet you I do
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]